So, let’s just come out and say it: everybody
poops.
But what happens if you don’t?
Constipation.
Hey guys, Amy with you on DNews.
Going poo might make all emotional 12-year-olds
giggle, but no going poo is no laughing matter.
When everything is healthy and normal, smooth
muscles in the intestines move food along
allowing your body to absorb nutrients and
water along the way.
Anything that stays in your digestive tract
long enough to reach the colon is waste, and
it’s compacted and excreted.
But we all get constipated.
Almost everyone will experience this uncomfortable
feeling and the bloating and cramping that
comes with it at least once in their lives.
According to the American College of Gastroenterology,
constipation is one of the most frequent GI
problems in the US with at least 2.5 million
poop-related doctor visits every year.
Constipation happens when your body draws
too much water out of the passing food, drying
out the mass as it approaches your colon.
The dryer your poop is, the harder it is to
pass.
You might not be able to pass dry stool for
a day or two, but once it’s been three days
since your last bowel movement you’re considered
constipated.
Three days is the average time it takes for
the stool in your system to get dry and hard.
*** Yes, you’re still processing food so
making more poo
We usually get it when traveling.
The sudden change of your diet and a disruption
of your daily routine can throw your body’s
natural process into disarray.
Your body will want to poop, but you’re
sleeping.
Or you might be on a plane and choose to hold
it in instead of braving the airplane washroom.
Speaking of, opinions differ on the question
of holding in a poo.
Konstantin Monastyrsky, author of Gut Sense,
says holding your stool in, even once, is
dangerous because it allows stools to stack
on top of one another.
And they dry out, they block your system and
can lead to an impacted bowel.
Prevention magazine, on the other hand, says
that while holding it in won’t make you
feel great, doing it once or twice is probably
ok.
Which is probably good since most of us will
try and hold it until we can get to a bathroom.
But making a habit of it is dangerous.
Kyle Staller, a gastroenterologist at Massachusetts
General Hospital says that people who are
in the habit of holding in their poop because
of their jobs — think nurses, teachers,
or long-haul truck drivers — are more likely
to become constipated or even develop dysfunction
in the muscles used for pooping.
And while laxatives might help, they’re
really only a short term solution.
Overuse of laxatives can actually cause the
muscles in your colon to forget how to form
and excrete waste.
Your body can forget how to poo!
So holding it in is bad.
And gross.
If you don’t poo when you need to, all the
waste and toxins your body wants to excrete
is just sitting in there.
And you continue making waste, adding to the
mass and also stopping toxins trying to get
out of your organs.
You’re slowly poisoning yourself.
The mass keeps building up in your colon,
eventually leading to an impacted bowel.
An impacted bowel can cause circulation problems,
heart problems, as well as horrible cramping,
a distended gut, and a lot of pain.
Enemas help relieve impacted bowels, but sometimes
surgery is required, and if left untreated,
an impacted bowel can kill you.
Best defenses against constipation?
Eat enough fibre and drink enough water to
keep your body happy and healthy, go when
you feel the need, and take your time!
Scientists aren’t entirely sure why, but
coffee helps you go, so try sipping that morning
cup on the toilet.
Your colon will thank you.
To learn more about the weird friendship between
coffee and poop, check out this incredible
animated video:
Why Does Coffee Make You Poop?
(animated ep)
We’ll have a link in the description if
you’re on mobile.
How do you guys deal with constipation?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe for more DNews every day
of the week.
How do you guys deal with constipation?
Let us know in the comments below and keep
coming back to Test Tube for more DNews every
single day of the week.
How do you guys deal with constipation?
Let us know on the Discovery News Facebook
page or on Twitter @DNews.
And you can find me; I’m @astvintagespace.
Thanks for watching!